كل ما في الجنوب من رنا في جميع أنحاء
العالم ، يأتي تجمع الجينات من هذه البثرة ،
إنه نوع له
أهمية كبيرة في عالم الحفظ ،
أعني أنه لامتياز كبير للعمل
في هذه الحديقة
[موسيقى]
تاريخيًا كنا دائمًا  تم
تدريبهم دائمًا على التعامل مع
إمبالا شراء لحوم الطرائد باستخدام
رجال SI ربما ربما سكاكين الأدغال وغيرها من الأفخاخ
و 2011 وتغير الديناميكي لأن
النقابات الدولية كانت
تشارك وأعتقد أن بلاء
الصيد الجائر هاجر جنوبًا من
الأجزاء الشمالية من إفريقيا حيث كان
العداء  لقد تم محوها ،
هذا ما نسميه مركز الأعصاب HRP
هذا هو المكان الذي توجد فيه
قاعدة جمع المعلومات الاستخبارية حيث
يرتبطون جميعًا بالإنترنت ويرسلون
صورهم مباشرة إلى مركز الأعصاب
حتى نعرف بالضبط مكان
الكاميرا حيث توجد الصورة  يأتي
من ويمكننا الرد بسرعة كبيرة ،
لذلك هناك عمليات نشر ولكننا نعلم أننا
نعرف مكان المشكلة ويجب
عليهم الوصول إلى هناك بسرعة كبيرة  لي
أن أصدقاء المروحية الجدد الآن
استغرقوا 8 دقائق فقط من استلام النواة
إلى النشر ، وسوف يستغرقون 7
دقائق أخرى للوصول إليها مرة أخرى بدون
التكنولوجيا التي من المحتمل أن تكون قد اتخذت
في منطقتك ، لقد فات الأوان
حيث نحن  كنت تخسر ما بين 10 و 15 من
وحيد القرن في الشهر ، الأمر الذي أوقفها
تمامًا ، لقد كنت من دعاة الحفاظ على البيئة
لسنوات عديدة ، كان جدي الأكبر
حارسًا للعبة في هذه الحديقة
والحفاظ على ما
هو عداء في الجنوب أمر بالغ الأهمية لا يمكننا السماح به
الاختفاء سيكون أمرًا مروعًا بالنسبة
لك أن تفكر في
[موسيقى]